I'm in one of the Udacity
tablet studios.
Any time you see this pen,
you are actually watching a video
that's taking place right here.
Anyway, back to the subject at hand.
Unfortunately we can't teach
you everything there is
to know about the world
of web development.
At some point you'll be on your own and
you'll need to learn some
new technique or technology.
So instead of focusing directly on
teaching you everything that you could
ever know, we want to make sure that
you're ready to be independent.
We want you to be able to
figure out new techniques and
technologies on your own and thrive in
what ever the web dev world becomes.
So, to start all of that off,
I want to go back to the very beginning.
Some of you may recognize this.
This is Netscape Navigator indeed
it was the first major web browser.
It was released in 1994 and it was
based on the earlier Mosaic browser.
Which was developed by the University
of Illinois back in 1993.
Of course navigator peaked in
popularity in the 90s, and eventually
Microsoft's Internet Explorer came to
dominate the web browser landscape.
Development on Navigator stopped.
But you can still trace features in code
in older versions of Internet Explorer
in Mozilla's Firefox all the way
back to Netscape Navigator.
In fact Netscape Navigator looks
pretty similar to the browsers that
we still have today.
There's a URL bar at the top and
then a big viewpoint to consume content.
Nowadays web developers use three
different languages to develop websites.
HTML, which stands for
Hypertext Markup Language.
CSS, which stands for
cascading style sheets.
And JavaScript, which,
well I guess just stands for JavaScript.
In a nutshell,
HTML describes the content and
structure of a website,
CSS describes the styling of a website.
And JavaScript handles
all the interactions.
You'll be learning all about
these three languages.
In the lessons to come.
However, this situation with HTML,
CSS and
JavaScript hasn't always been the case.
The early web was almost
entirely all text documents
with maybe a couple images,
kind of like newspapers.
As a result the first
browsers only supported HTML.
CSS and JavaScript didn't exist yet.
Believe it or
not this is the first web site.
The web wasn't originally designed for
big applications like Facebook and
Gmail.
It was developed as a way for
text documents to directly
link to one another.
You can see all of
the links on this page.
The links were meant to mimic references
that you would find in bibliographies or
annotations in research papers.
In fact the academic route should be
pretty obvious because this website is
from CERN.
Which is the nuclear
institute in Europe.
At the time, these links were really
nothing more than ways of referencing
other people's work.
Check it out.
This was the first Microsoft home page.
Over time developers started
adding styles to their content.
Changing colors and fonts and
backgrounds and a little bit of layout.
All of these changes
ended up in the HTML.
And the code was a huge mess.
Now you're looking at the Yahoo
homepage around the year 2000.
This image is actually courtesy of
the Internet Archive Wayback Machine.
Which is a kind of
hilarious way to check out
older websites if you want to
see how the web used to look.
Anyway, CSS came on
the scene around 1996 as
developers really wanted to add more and
more and more styles to their pages.
With CSS, developers could
then separate these styles,
like deciding how all of these
will look, from the content.
Which is essentially all
of the text on this page.
Of course, that's just HTML and CSS.
Then there is JavaScript.
JavaScript is a different
beast all together.
While HTML and CSS are markup languages.
And that is to say, they're only
used to describe other documents.
JavaScript is a full on
programming language.
It allows developers to
change the content and
the style of a live web site.
JavaScript has had
an interesting history.
It was developed in 1995 by
a guy named Brendan Eich.
And he did it in ten days.
That is crazy.
You may not know much about
programming now or maybe you do, but
either way that is an impressive feat.
He created JavaScript to
run in Netscape Navigator.
Today, JavaScript runs
in every browser and
is one of the most popular
programming languages period.
Thanks to the popularity of the web.
JavaScript runs in a huge number of
environments outside of browsers.
Including servers with
software like Node.js and
microcontrollers like Tessel.io.
All right, and speaking of popularity,
it's easy to assume that
JavaScript is an offshoot of
the programming language Java.
Because of their similar names.
Java was hugely popular in 1995 and
in fact it still is today.
As it turns out though, Java and
JavaScript are in no way related.
I mean,
there are a couple syntax similarities.
But that doesn't change the fact that
the name JavaScript was basically just
a marketing decision to
piggyback on Java's popularity.
True story.